and now tim dillon is
going to hell
uh welcome to tim dillon is going to
hell everybody uh
congrats to booga who won the uh
fortnight world cup
he is my best friend he is 16.
uh i'm a gamer many of you know this
uh i love gaming and the whole gaming
community
and it is a honor to call booga
i think that's how you pronounce it
booga
uh he is a friend uh
a confidant that's what i do i'm
35 and i watch people play video games
on twitch that's what i do that's how i
spend my
time on this earth and if you tell me
that that's not a good use of my time
if you attack me and say
that my time could be better spent doing
other things
i will react like an animal that has
been backed into a corner
i will react like a feral possum
in a garbage can if you even suggest to
me kindly
that i should do something else
if you tell me that i should not go
to a theme park designed for children
i am going to lash out
in in in a myriad of ways i am going to
lose
my mind i'm going to view it as you
trying to
kill me and my family if you just
suggest
that i potentially find something else
to do
then go to a theme park designed
for really toddlers
in my mid-30s because that's an attack
on me because
you know not everybody's parents had the
wherewithal
financially to bring them to disney
world when they were children
so for those of you who those of us
who missed out on that
it's important that we recapture that
experience at 38.
we shouldn't just move on and go you
know everyone is not going to have
every experience in life
everyone won't but they they
should and i think resigning yourself to
that idea
that maybe you've just missed the
[ __ ] window
for disney world is defeatist attitude
i think you got to go out no matter what
age
because we're all kids inside right
won't that be jeffrey epstein's defense
we're all kids inside and if you suggest
for a moment to me
that i should not
try to write every wrong from my
childhood
now of course folks i'm doing a
character i don't
i don't believe what i'm saying that is
that is part of the comedic effect of
what i'm doing i
am i am playing a character of someone i
i have been to disney world twice when i
was a child
when i was supposed to enjoy it i did
not enjoy it
as a child in fact and i know that this
is really the opposite
of what is said i worry about the
children who do
enjoy it i worry about the children who
like the torture of other human beings
that they're made to walk around in
costumes in 102 degree weather
um i worry about those children that
don't see through
this even at a young age
um but there was an article written in
the new york post
about millennials visiting disney world
because some woman
on facebook some
rant went viral where she was angry
that there was a lot of millennials
walking around disney world
preventing her and her child from
getting a pretzel you know or going on
the rides
or or whatever and and and i don't know
her i'm not
necessarily in her camp
why number one why are you getting a
pretzel
in disney world is that why you went
is that why your fat child went to
disney world
i'm pretty sure you could have satiated
him
at a rest stop if that was the big
issue if he just needed a carb
maybe you didn't need to spend all that
money
to go to the theme park
but she was angry that her son
whose blood sugar levels were rapidly
dropping in the park
could not she could not procure
a pretzel for her child so
she lashed out at who she felt was the
culprit
childless millennials who were in the
park now
you know it's a tough
thing here because i have friends
that really love disney world
um and that counts
as a mark against them
when i think of them nobody's perfect i
have a lot of marks against
me when people think of me as a friend
you know there's a lot of things that go
in my negative column
what will he bring up what will he feel
is appropriate to discuss
at a barbecue you know
you know what rage-filled diatribe
will he go into without anyone even
inviting that kind of energy he will
just show up and bring it
now i understand that but to me
disney world i went twice i went when i
was a child
my parents went and this is true to try
to save their marriage
this is a fact uh my my
parents my boomer parents
went to disney world to try to
save what was a
failing marriage and everybody knew that
at that point they were sleeping in
separate rooms my mother had taken in
this girl dorothy who was like my
babysitter
and dorothy came from a real crack
family
and my mother said come to our home
which is also relatively unhappy
but none of us are on crack because my
mother was actually like a giving person
she was a good person
she helped the girl get into college and
everything like that and then of course
as soon as a girl got into college and
you know did everything she she left she
never
spoke to us again you know whatever it
is what it is
uh but we all went down to disney world
uh and uh me my father
my mother and dorothy this kind of
broad-shouldered brutish
woman that my mother not
she was i'm trying to remember what she
looked like
some people found her attract she had it
she had a masculine energy
the woman she did women got to watch out
when
a lot of women that are swimmers their
shoulders get
very aggressive you know
um and you notice that if you watch the
olympics and you see females that are
swimmers
their shoulders are very you know and
that was dorothy's deal too
pretty but you know built so my
father my mother and dorothy and myself
went to disney world
this is maybe 1993
for i'm seven or eight years old we go
to disney world
we stay in the grand floridian which is
i believe still the top hotel
it's still the top hotel i first of all
i will say this about disney world if
you're not staying on the property
guys if you're not even staying on the
property
i mean what kind of experience
and everywhere in disney world takes
three and a half hours to get to
even if you're staying on the property
you gotta take a monorail
a boat a train and my mother and father
hated each other with passion
okay so my mother and insisted that we
all take
naps in the in the middle of the day
which is actually not a bad idea
uh you you go to disney world in the
morning you go to the character
breakfast which
my mother and father i swear to god
fought so bitterly
at the character breakfast that none of
the characters would come near the table
they were all orbiting around the table
none of them wanted to come near the
table
because my mother and father were
fighting about money
that's why all marriages fail for the
most part is because you have too little
money
or you have too much money and if you
have too much money you go why am i
[ __ ] you
what you need in a marriage is just
enough money to keep
people doing it but you need a little
bit of fear
you need a little bit of the idea of
like can we afford this divorce
what happens what happens on the other
side of this
if everyone is too comfortable one of my
friends is a divorce lawyer in beverly
hills
too much comfort breeds just people
going you know what
i don't know i don't know anymore
you don't really excite me but just
enough money
just enough keeps people like my parents
in a loveless
marriage for 20 years and and ruins
their children's life
so that's what you want you want just
enough
money to keep things going you know
divorce is such a big deal and most
people don't realize it
a friend of mine said recently and he
said this and this is this is aggressive
and you know people are going to get
angry
but when you are a child of divorce it
really
extinguishes the hope that you're really
ever going to have a
normal and i don't want to use the word
normal but a conventional
life like i think the way that he worded
it is you're just kind of like
you're [ __ ] you're damaged now because
everything is so bad now
divorce barely registers as something
that damages people
because everything's like so bad kids
are in cages
everybody's on heroin kids are in foster
care
they're being farmed out cps is stealing
kids and selling them to senators
so a divorce is like good that's like
the good option oh
oh your parents just got divorced that's
like great that's like phenomenal but
the reality is
it's not it's really not okay mommy and
daddy going you know what we're not into
this anymore
and we're barely into you because that's
what a divorce is at the end of the day
it's them going we're so not into each
other
that you are no longer even uniting us
for a few years
you actually were the drive because
that's also why people get
divorced because they don't have kids
you need to have a child if you're
married
because otherwise what are you doing
it's stupid
marriage without children is kind of
dumb unless you were like trying if
you're running like an empire
and your days are full of meetings
and whatever it is and and you know
going on
you know retreats and whatever it is
that keeps you and that person
really but otherwise it's a child and if
it's not a child
you're all you're you're heading towards
the end
it's just a matter of time i had a
friend recently not if not really a
friend i call everyone a friend on the
show i have three friends but
everyone's a friend no one's a friend to
be honest with you i have i
i you know everybody's getting canceled
we're going to go through that later in
the program
and i want you to start canceling people
from your inner circle
i've recently telling you cancel your
family you should have done that already
cancel your extended family and your
acquaintances
now i want you to start canceling your
close friends that you've known for a
very long time
and we'll get into why later um but
the reality is divorce is a thing people
act like it's not a thing people
people tend to think it like doesn't
matter but it's traumatizing especially
if
it goes on for a while like my parents
divorce went on for two years because
neither
one of them could afford to get lawyers
so they had a mediator
and a mediator just comes to your house
and your parents just argue at a dining
room table over
a collection of beanie babies or
whatever the [ __ ] they had
these [ __ ] boomers had nothing they
had a few lamps
aunt gussie's table i remember my mother
said that she goes well who's gonna get
aunt gussy's table
and i'm like hi i'm 13
and i'm about to embark on a decade of
drug use
could one of you maybe check in perhaps
while we're dividing up a table that has
a market value of at best
75 dollars i'm a living organism that
you both have created
so could potentially maybe you find the
time
to check in on how i'm doing while you
divide up all the winnings
of 20 years of of having no college
education
and no financial planning okay and
believing you could retire by collecting
hes
trucks and then putting them in a room
and my father who i love who came to my
show last night in new york
by my dad being a musician and you know
his most prized possessions were his
guitars
this isn't they're just boomers it's not
really specific to them do you know how
many [ __ ] people messaged me after
that boomerant they were like
[ __ ] man wow these they're just dealing
with the tools
imagine you were on acid in a field
listening to jimi hendrix and then snap
that's over and you gotta get a job
and reagan's in office and everybody's
like you gotta work now
and you're like wait what what about the
revolution now you have kids
and you gotta pack them a school lunch
and you can't just play guitar anymore
naked you know and slide down a hill i
get it
it was jarring but divorce
is more of a thing than people tend to
tend to give it credit for
i'm afraid of divorce journey these kids
have to go and testify in a court
do you know how much this [ __ ] up
children having to testify
and get cross-examined and then bringing
in experts and stuff like that
i mean i am not a religious person by
nature
i am not uh somebody who's
like i'm not into cults really um
[Music]
other than comedy which certainly is a
religion
and it makes the least sense of all of
them
and i'm including even the forms of
christianity where they baptize you with
like 40
and you you know take a little bus by
the way
is there any better movie robert duvall
is the apostle
what a great film go watch the apostle
with robert duvall
i want to get into [ __ ] evangelical
christianity after watching that i want
to
go to one of those swamp like churches
it's so great
um but i'm not a religious person or
mosaic should i join mosaic which is the
la church
everybody's really hot at mosaic
everybody's
hot and all the actors are members of it
and they all
they all go there and they have like
rock bands playing and everybody's like
got a guitar and it's electric guitar
and they're like
jesus said to be an influencer
you know it's it's it's what's great
about mosaic is it marries
uh the two things that jesus really
cared about faith and being an
influencer
and uh that's what they're about there
they don't really like gays too much
they don't say they don't like gays
because they're in la
so they don't let gays occupy the higher
tier positions of the church
somebody was telling me this like i gave
a [ __ ] like some gay person was like
talking to me they're like you know what
the mosaic church uh if you're gay you
can't
occupy the high so i'm like oh so in the
cult that you've willingly joined
you can't ascend to the higher tier of
the pretend cult that you attend
every week well i am sorry what a
tragedy for you
i'm very sad it's really nuts like
somebody coming up to you talking about
you know scientology being like you know
you know i really just aren't i'm not
advancing
in the way that i feel like i should be
yeah don't be
in it then i don't know what to tell you
i don't know why you're in it anyway
mosaic
i mean it is it's nice looking there's
some really gorgeous people to go
i get it i get why people want spiritual
i'm not against it by the way
i'm not against religion i know i [ __ ]
on certain things because it's funny but
everybody needs something and i totally
[ __ ] get it
so i i if you're out there and you're a
religious person
good for you okay but divorce
is one of those things that does [ __ ]
kids up
nobody nobody cares but it does i'm not
saying and listen
i'm not don't obviously don't stay
together
if it's the worst marriage in the world
that can also [ __ ] kids up
that's people's argument they're like
well should we stay together if we're
just
beating each other it's like no the goal
would be to not be in the worst
marriage in the world to try to not get
into that now obviously
sometimes that just happens i get it
so my family went to disney world
and this was really right before things
fell apart things were being held
together i mean this was really
when you look back it's really after
things fell apart but before
you know the consequences of that it's
what it really is
they were at the the table at the grand
floridian
character breakfast and i remember it
and i remember my father shoving what
i imagine was a competently cooked egg
in his mouth because it is a nice hotel
and i remember he looked at my mother
and he goes will you shut the [ __ ] up
so these things will come over here he
called them things
which by the way he is right about he's
absolutely right
like there was no romanticizing of what
this place was
which i kind of now in hindsight
appreciate he wasn't like
so mickey will come over he was like so
this thing because it ain't mickey
you don't know who is in that suit
why has there never been a documentary
about the dark side of disney world
they are so powerful disney is so
[ __ ]
powerful has there ever been a doc have
you ever seen anything i mean maybe i'm
wrong i think banksy did that thing on
it
what did he do he went in there to the
uh the the little children one that it's
a small world after all it's a small
world and he did the
he dressed a guy in a guantanamo bay
outfit
and he hung him from or like a roller
coaster he like had a hanging guantanamo
bay prisoner and he did it with that uh
that mr brainwash yeah americans don't
notice they think it's great
look there's a gitmo prisoner this is a
good ride
i thought this ride was for [ __ ] but
it's good
i i thought a small world was for
[ __ ] i fought my wife
but i didn't know we were going to see
muslims get hung
this is great that'll make it the most
popular ride in the whole [ __ ] place
they love it yeah banksy hung this
guantanamo bay
yeah it was the longest line at the
whole park they're hanging muslims in
there
it's worth the wait
no but i mean like is there a dot
there's no doc nobody's done a doc cause
you can't shoot in there right right
the florida project which was a
phenomenal movie which got no emmys was
ignored
because it was about poor whites i hate
to say it that's really what it was
and that's the reality and and none and
we don't
i don't consider those people white
number one and neither does any white
person
like knowing like and i don't mean and
i'm not saying what like like when you
when that girl who did a great job
whatever her name
i forgot bria vinnette i'm phenomenal
she was barely an actress
they they cast her on instagram they
gave her some acting lessons and she
[ __ ] knocked it out of the park and
that little girl
i think her name was brooklyn whatever
whatever she was great too but like
she's living in a in a
in a in a hotel in florida a motel
uh that really exists and the florida
project actually used some of the real
people that live in the mote i mean
hopefully they paid them
probably not hey can we just put a
camera uh
in front of your horror do you mind that
um but it was a great thing but it
didn't tackle sexuality it didn't tackle
race it didn't tackle
you know it was just a poor white chick
who's like you know how i'd be doing
so it's like again this ain't
bush white it ain't country club white
this isn't scandinavian nordic white
eating salmon
this is [ __ ] how you doing like
that person doesn't want to be white it
was in the florida part like
but it was a great movie but at the end
of it they shot in disney world but they
shot it on a phone
secretively remember that right right
yeah
i remember you showing me some uh what
was it the florida man
some dock called the yeah florida i
think it was called
well that's a great doc about florida
yeah i just wonder and
i i could be wrong there could be a book
about this somebody could hit me up
there doesn't seem to be any like let's
pull back the veil on disney world
because
there's got to be [ __ ] going on yeah i
think
i think one of the heiresses or somebody
recently like one of the
the family i could be wrong in this
maybe look this up
was kind of alarmed that the people at
the park
weren't making enough money she was kind
of like i'm kind of shocked that they're
not making money
i'm pretty sure this was disney world
because you know that there's issues in
a place like disney world
and i mean there's got to be yeah this
this happened right yeah
yeah it's loading right now yeah so it's
the harris to disney
disney harris says she's livid about
disneyland wages and working conditions
right right she's the granddaughter of
walt disney company
she's the next person they're gonna hang
and it's a small world
she'll be the next she's already a
pirates of the caribbean
she's already been thrown into the lake
okay where she was so what i'm saying is
there's got to be
a dock to be made but you probably
figure if i make it i don't work again
right and don't [ __ ] d i ain't making
that [ __ ]
i ain't making that no i don't have the
money to make it
but if i did have the money to make it i
wouldn't because
i think i have a long future with disney
um
but my father and my mother
took us to disney world and i remember
it being fine
my mother was like we got a nap in the
middle of the day and then we'll go out
at night which is kind of a good idea we
did the morning then we took a nap
because in the middle of the day it's
the hottest and the most crowded
so my mom is actually pretty smart you
know i mean
so she established that rule
but it's also tough to force a nap
like everyone's forcing a nap it's tough
but it is a better system it's just
tough just tough it at 1 pm
when everybody else is at the park we're
going back
to the room and my mother's like go to
bed
go to sleep and then she made us go to
epcot nobody wants to go to [ __ ]
epcot but epcot was not i mean we did go
to a nice french restaurant there are
some nice restaurants in epcot you know
um the second time i returned to disney
world
was i loved there's a movie called
noises off sometimes i got to recommend
these things to you people because many
of you
uh live in in cultural wastelands i can
see that you message me sometimes i'll
friend you back and
i know that there's a movie called
noises off with michael kane
john ritter christopher walken mary lou
henner
[ __ ] carol burnett it's about a
broadway play
that just falls apart every night and
everybody hates each other
and it really gets close to what it is
to be in the be in any type of arts
where everyone hates each other
and everyone's a delusional psychopath
who thinks they're essential
and michael kane has a line in this that
i absolutely love
he goes he's talking about how bad the
play was and he goes nothing could
prepare us i think it was cleveland he
goes
nothing could prepare us for cleveland
it was the final horror
and i always remember the second time i
went to disney world was the final
horror
i was in a dance troupe
because i was an actor i was a thespian
i was an actor
and you had to learn how to dance and
sing to be a child actor so i was a tap
dancer
and i was in a a school in long island
new york called
legs they're very creative in long
island have we mentioned that
have we touched on the limitless
creativity and talent of those people
i think we have well the school was
called legs
and i was chosen to be the boogie woogie
bugle boy
in the boogie woogie bugle boy dance
number which is a song
the boogie boogie boo good and
i was a little fat preteen just
starting to go through puberty just
starting to get my newly fat body
as my mother said to me once she goes
you're a mesomorph you collect weight in
your stomach i'm like
well how about we not eat fast food
every night
and watch television could any could
anyone suggest another course of action
thank god for like joe rogan telling
people how to be healthy thank god
everything now is about the celebration
of being 700 pounds
and on nine medications like thank god
that there's some
there are some people out there that go
maybe that's not the move okay
so we go down there as a dance troupe
i'm the boogie woogie bugle boy i don't
know what you think when you think
you're going to perform at disney world
you you probably imagine that there's
going to be
some magical you know big
theater or like it's going to be at
night
it's going to be well lit there's going
to be a lot of people that are excited
to see you
or whatever um they set up a stage
by the bathrooms and
it was in the middle of the day and it
was dog
heat dog heat florida humidity
okay and a lot of people in the dance
troupe because they were from long
island
were a bit paunchy even the ladies
they were a bit punchy okay not all of
them
but some of them were you know
this wasn't exactly the top tier this
wasn't like winning the dance
competitions
this was like the leftovers okay
and so that trip we stayed at a hotel
called the dolphin
and i remember me
and a bunch of fat chicks in
boogie boogie boogle boy outfits these
were
these were like tan military outfits
and they were hot and we were sweating
through them even as children
we looked like we looked like a regiment
of
soldiers that the government would just
try out like some
like you know mind control drug on you
know like just the forgotten platoon
of soldiers that like no one would even
go back for
like leave them they're all dead just
say they're dead
you know we'll tell their parents their
debt you know
there was no saving private ryan for
this group
i'll tell you that much if you took a
look at us we're done
and we would take a boat from the
dolphin at disney world every day
and just just just chubby kids
sweating through uh tan
weird military uniforms and then we
would go to this stage
by the bathrooms and flail around
in the heat and fat taurus
would stare at us while they were on the
line for the bathroom
while they were choking down a churro
and they would just stare at us and we
would dance and then afterwards there
was like
very little clapping you know which is
so embarrassing very it was kind of like
they were like people like
and then we would do it again like five
minutes later then we would keep doing
the same
the same number so we didn't have any
other number if we keep doing the same
number
and they'd already seen it so now like
they would look away
now they would like they now no one even
had cell phones
so they couldn't even look at their
phone they were just literally staring
at other things
and like we would be performing at
people's back source so
that was a low point in my life that
even splash mountain couldn't fix
splash mountain was fun but i remembered
as i was coming down splash mountain i'm
like
oh this is life for most people it's
just
drudgery and hell and you get one moment
of weightlessness
where water is sprayed in your face and
then they hand you a picture and they go
get the [ __ ] out and that's what
happened to us
so if you connect with disney world like
some of my friends do and they're good
people
jared logan a friend of mine who's a
comedian made a great point he goes
disney is the first
culture that you're introduced to as a
child but it
shouldn't be the last you should go and
find
other things that speak to you as well
don't be like my friend michael who goes
i don't like movies or tv and i'm like
why he's like
i don't like fake [ __ ]
he's like sports has all the drama you
need
he goes all the drama you need is in
sports
nothing can compete with sports
okay nothing not a novel
nothing nothing can compete with a
playoff game
that's it and i'm not knocking sports i
get how
engrossing sports is in for [ __ ]
great reason but
come on so those are my experiences
personally with disney world and i and
and i so i had a couple on my tour bus
once because i was a tour guide new york
city
and they got on and they had disney
shirts on
and it's very interesting when you meet
people who they don't only enjoy disney
world it's their brand
it's who they are as people and when
you're older you should realize that oh
that's not goofy that's a person
who's dying in a hundred degree weather
in a suit
with probably a rash that is now
bleeding
and they're not being paid well they
probably don't have health insurance
they're about to pass out
that's best case worst case they're
they're [ __ ] a pedophile cop and
feels all day
you know there's a few of them in there
that are like look at me
i got it so
by the way that would be great how many
people have been asked to leave
disney because of those issues
where's that where's that article julie
k
brown miami herald jane mayer
how about you go down there
so but these two people on my tour bus
they said we were gonna take a
they go i said you like new york and
there you go
and by the way i'm out of new york i'm
full-time in la
i i'm done with new york but
there's a few things that i require from
a friend
one that you believe that uh society is
on the verge of imminent collapse
that helps that helps only because
there's there's less of a learning curve
with our friendship
if you're there already then we can have
a little fun
that doesn't mean you don't do good
things go go do good things
but it just means that you have the
awareness
to know that like even though things are
good
in the square foot you're standing on
earth
down the block there's massive problems
okay that's one of the requirements i
have another requirement i have
is that you um
are what was i just saying i just lost
myself
right before the requirement for friends
oh right before the requirement uh no
because he um i prefer you not to take
cruises
i i prefer you not to be the type of
person
who needs to have your life planned for
you
and like like there's a certain type of
person who just
does what everyone else does all the
time
and i get it when you're single there's
the idea that like
there's these things are created for you
to maybe meet other people
okay but if you have someone in your
life
the idea that you're still going with
the flow
the idea that you're still going on a
vacation where people have plant like
planned it for you you don't have any
independent thought
um bothers me but
these two people were on my bus and oh
yeah so here's one of my requirements
you cannot hate new york
i just don't i i i mean you could i
you can complain about it you can say
that it
is a it dehumanizes people
and it it is designed to crush
people and destroy people
and i would agree with all of that but
you still
have to not hate it like theo von's
producer this guy johnny
good looking guy i was talking to him on
instagram the other day
he's an actor and he goes as he's going
to new york and i'm like hey man
new york's cool and he's like no i hate
new york la's much better
now here's the thing i like him
he's a good guy i don't know him but i
give good-looking people
all the chances in the world you know
he's on the show power
now the show power is for people with a
75 iq
when the one on star stars has never
made a show
for people that have over a 90 iq that's
just not that what they're going for
they want people that are very confused
and so that's what power is okay and he
was also in the movie ma
now ma is
a film that no one talked about i can
only imagine
because it was like a level of
horrific because it's what is it
octavius spencer is is
it's a horror movie where octavius
spencer goes around and stabs people
whatever it is so now now he's an actor
and he's he's he's he's working and i
respect the hell out of that
but these la guys
sometimes they do stuff and it ain't
good
and they get rewarded for it because
they're good-looking
and they're hard-working and the things
they do
a lot not all the time and johnny's
probably a good act i don't know
but a lot of times these la guys they do
things
that are no good
they're no good and new york is a place
that really
at one time provided itself on things
being
good and so sometimes people get a
little
threatened or whatever but he said to me
he's like you know
i hate new york i just sent him a photo
of oscar i'm like dude
maybe he was kidding i don't know but i
get why people like la if you're just a
hot
person la's where it's at for you if
you're a hot person
who's maybe not super fond of books
la's where it's at you know
uh but the thing is you can't hate new
york so these two
this couple on my tour bus i go what do
you think in new york they go
uh
and they had the disney shirts on and
they go they go
to be honest we're a little disappointed
we're gonna take a disney cruise
we've taken three of them so we decided
we were gonna go to new york this time
but we we we don't really we don't
really we don't really like
new york we actually were just talking
about that we should have been on a
disney cruise or they said or
go to disney world and i go well why do
you go to disney world they go well it's
the best place
on earth and i go well why i know that
that's kind of their
logo slogan or whatever but tell me why
tell me why it is and they go
it's just great they go it's great you
can have so much fun they go it's all
there
they go it's all there the guy said and
i go what is there
can you explain to me what is there
new york we have some of the best
museums
the best restaurants we have central
park we have five boroughs
we have history culture got all this
[ __ ] we got beaches
we got the hudson river and our i mean i
met you know you know who did new york
right man [ __ ]
in shape scandinavians man they're like
yeah they're like we went we took a
train an hour out of the city we went
kayaking in the hudson river
i'm like yeah yeah you know who doesn't
do that
americans they don't do that cause they
don't fit in the kayak
so they don't do that they just walk
around
times square and eat food that people
hand them
and fart and and everything's too busy
and crowded and they take the tour bus
because they don't want to walk
and they didn't really get into new york
they're like how do people live
i i have 90 000 acres
for 14 dollars i'm like i understand
that sir you live on the skinwalker
ranch
okay with a bunch of grays
it's for my conspiracy heads you know
where i'm at you know where i'm at
but okay yeah we get it yeah the price
per square foot's a bit higher here sir
that was everyone's favorite thing to do
when they visited new york they were
like huh
what what's this cost 5 000
i've got 90 million acres
for four dollars i know sir
i know i understand that and i'm sure
it's great
by the looks of you sir i am sure it's
great i'm sure you're making use of all
of that space
but so this couple they started to get
angry at me because i kept pressing them
like what is
there what is there it's all there
and then they just got like angry they
were like mad
they're like new york they're like
first of all disney world's crowded but
the reality is they were these just big
oaf-like
children okay they probably didn't have
sex
they probably went to their hotel room
every night and just like
held hands until they and then went into
their bathroom one at a time and
masturbated
because they were probably like children
that had never had a sexual awakening
that's what i imagined that they were
there's many people in this comedy
industry like that i look at certain
agents and managers and they're like
and i'm like oh you've never uh you've
never had sex
with a man or a woman or you're just
you know that's why you're you know
getting off
on roast battle but
so these two let's call them tards
i when i was a kid my favorite vacation
because i was a kid i was a little
[ __ ] so i wanted to go to rich
i wanted to go to nice places because
gay people
have taste not all of them but some of
them now i know you're looking at me and
you're like
oh look at your shirt that's not okay i
get it
i'm not a fashionista but what i'm
telling you is i like to go
to places that are that are a little bit
exclusive
they're lit they're a little bit roped
off you don't invite the world
okay like i have friends that are like i
had a friend go
don't you want to go to the olympics i
said only if we're
committing an act of terrorism that
would be the only way i would feel
that i would want to go is if we were
really focused
and we were really you know uh
my favorite i i used to look up these
places like i would call them
i'd read magazines this is all kind of
pre-internet i'd call nice hotels in new
york and i'd have them send me brochures
like the four seasons the lowell hotel
where eric clapton used to
smoke cigars in the lobby you people
know this that are listening in ohio and
i mean
uh anyway i'm not nagging ohio relax
calm down if you're sensitive
get out of here you're not but so i like
the good life because there's a little
[ __ ] you know that
the good life is good you know people
you look you look at the world you're
like these are cretins some of these
people
out there i like something that's a
little different so i made my dad take
me
to a place called the bland tire now the
bland tire
was in western mountain it was in i
don't know somewhere in
the hills of massachusetts it was like a
relay in chateau is a group that
uh has a bunch of restaurants and a
bunch of hotels they're very nice like
inns
country ends all over the world but
there's a lot in america
and i said to my dad let's go to the
blantire i had to kind of beg him
he goes okay i'll take you there i don't
think they allowed children
he had to literally call the bland tire
and go listen i'm going to take my son
there he's not a regular kid
he's not going to want to play baseball
he's not going to run around
you know he just if the only thing
that'll upset him is if the souffle
falls before it gets to the table then
he will have a full-on meltdown
okay please let us take this [ __ ] to
your castle
i imagine that was
the conversation now we went to the
bland tire
and immediately i i liked it immediately
because
as soon as we got out of the car they
looked at us like you don't belong here
and if you're ever in a place where
people treat you like you belong there
you're not in the right place you're in
the wrong
place friendliness is desperation
and fear that that's why disney world
everyone's manic
they're like welcome to disney world
because they're afraid
that you're gonna go write a yelp review
this place we got out and they were like
hello we went in
as we're checking in an old woman
with pearls she walks into this place
and she goes there was a guy there
and she goes excuse me i swear to god
this is like because the lobby and then
there's like the restaurant to the side
she goes
where's maurice and the guy
ma'am maurice is not here
but i have all of the instructions for
the event
i will be helping you everything is
exactly as as you wanted
and it was just a great moment and she
goes
excuse me and you could tell that this
man was not filled with
fear and trepidation and me and my
father immediately turned around and
loved it because we were both poor
and when you're poor nothing is better
than watching other poor people get
abused
it's great right it's like well it's not
my day today
it's his day so we turn around and she
goes i've planned everything with
maurice
find maurice and now this guy is like he
goes says again he's like man maurice is
not here today
she goes you need to get maurice
now and the guy the blood rushes out of
his face
he walks to the manager the managers are
scurrying around
and immediately i just feel this rush of
calm
come over my little 12 year old body i
knew that i was in the right
place i knew immediately that i was
where i belonged because here was a
woman
not gonna tolerate it she wasn't
going to tolerate anything other than
maurice
i swear to god that was the guy's name
it's hilarious that's like the name of
every [ __ ]
you know it's like right out of a
[ __ ] 80s movie and this woman was out
of date
so like those are the kind of occasions
like we didn't do i don't think we even
did anything for those two days
there was like a pool there was golf
maybe there was some other thing
we walked around the grounds we had like
a really nice dinner
but it was jujube just around other
people that were not
going to busch gardens you know
and so that's my only thing if you love
disney world god bless you good for you
i don't know that i want you in my life
there's reason to love disney world um
having down syndrome
being four these are all reasons
some people get married at disney world
can you imagine they get married in
front of the cat i mean
can you imagine i'm not saying listen i
live a very undignified life
it's just what i do it's just in the
cards
but require a little bit of dignity
to get married in front of the magic
kingdom in disney world to me
i mean have you never had a thought have
you never had a thought
in your head go
somewhere there are so many places in
the world to go
sometimes uh i've been getting into
watching uh
i'm i'm watching killer whales
torture seals which they do killer
whales by the way is why i didn't care
about blackfish
killer whales are vicious animals
uh people think they're like tuxedo
wearing fish
they're not they are vicious killers
and they torture the seal you could
youtube it you see the seal on the
little block of ice
and they're just kind of nudging it and
then finally that little
fat seal goes in the water and then they
they eat them
um and it is what it is it's it's the
it's the way the world it's the way the
natural world the natural world is
brutal it's cold
it's chaos that's what nature is i love
that woody allen when he goes i'm too
with nature
you know he's great reality well i mean
let's don't start
with me the reality is
there's a lot to be happy about in this
world i mean i know that you listen to
this show maybe you don't realize that
there's a lot to be happy about there's
a lot to look
at and just say you know what we've got
a lot of
stunning technological advancements that
have enabled us to
live these lives that would have been
unthinkable
even a decade ago which in the in the in
the whole
conception of history is really nothing
so you're lucky
you're lucky you're able to do things
that other people
would never have dreamed the internet
has
you know enabled you to collaborate with
other people
to compete
with other people to join
uh an online community to
market yourself to distribute your
products
to fully you know
really
put your mark on the world
you know many of you are are not doing
that
many of you are not doing that you're
spending time on social media you're
fighting you're upset
you're angry you're not taking the time
to put your self
out there you got to put yourself out
there
the world needs you
do you understand that are you listening
to me out there they need you
but how are they going to [ __ ] find
you how are they going to find you
they need to find you and you need
to have a website so that they can find
you
because they're gonna love you they're
gonna love
you they just don't
know it yet you're what they've been
looking for many of them are
puzzled they walk the earth
they're in fear they need someone to
show them the way
many of them are you know
suffering from many things
mental illness depression drug addiction
anxiety they've been horribly abused
they are broke uh
systemic oppression and they need
to find a light in this darkness
are you going to be that light are you
going to be
the person who helps them
get out of that dark hole that they live
in
that dark deep well that they've spent
most of their life in
screaming for anyone to come find them
and no one
finds it maybe every now and then
somebody throws change at them makes a
wish
but in the real world there are no
rescue missions
the whole town doesn't come out and with
you know that rope and
made of all those different
handkerchiefs they tie together to pull
you up that doesn't happen
the only hope that many of these people
have
when they're in the dark recesses of
their own mind the only hope that they
have
is going to your website and being
impressed by it
and saying look at this site
man this guy's got text he's got video
he's got all his links to his social
media
this guy's he's it's very helpful when
you see somebody else who's got it
together
you know um and i think that
if if if one of these people had have
seen your website
they may not go and shoot up their
school they may not go
shoot up they may not go
and you know commit
acts of depravity they may be impressed
that you've taken the time to use wix
that has over 200 stunning templates
they may be impressed that you've
designed your own website with a very
innovative
drag and drop design technology or that
you've just answered a few questions and
let wix adi do it for you they
they will know that they'll appreciate
that they'll see that someone else
out there in the world is making an
effort that's what it's all about you're
inspiring them without even
knowing it you've become a leader
okay just by having a website doesn't
matter what it's about
maybe you're a clown that goes to kids
parties and you want to advertise that
you show up and you dress like a clown
and
you make everybody happy and there's a
few testimonials from other families and
you go
you know john came in and really
brightened the day he really came in and
he brightened our day
and our child who's dead now but back
then
he was you know we have a straight
restraining order against him now he
can't come
he can't come near to the house because
he's eight years old and leading a local
militia
but back then he was very happy with the
clown that came and
we're very happy to give john our full
endorsement then people see this on your
website and they go
you know what maybe we should hire john
as a clown
i mean that's what it comes down to
folks i don't know how many times i have
to tell you this
but if you don't have a website you're a
piece of [ __ ]
i i mean if you don't have a [ __ ]
website
i don't care if you die i don't think
you should have health insurance
not without a website not without a
website
that's that's what they should check at
the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] you know i'm delirious i haven't
eaten i keep doing this but
what's the thing in the hospital the
front down see the front desk
i stay in so many hotels i think
everything's a hotel a hospital front
desk whatever it is you know what i'm
talking about
they should ask for your website not
your insurance card you have a website
they should look at it quickly
and if not it's you know if it looks
nice and you go oh you this person gives
a [ __ ]
we'll fix them we'll fix them you know
but if you don't have a website they
should open those doors and kick you out
and let you [ __ ] lay in the parking
lot and expire
okay because it's not just a matter of
having a website for you it's really for
the others it's for other people
that need to be inspired that's why i do
this show every week because people are
inspired
they're inspired by it and i many people
listen to the show and they
then they go and create families and
they create businesses and they create
art
and they create even if they're just
making a sandwich
it's i'm impressed that they've done it
you know they come in they make uh
maybe a turkey like cracked pepper
turkey on wheat
you go you know the reason i'm doing
that is because i just heard this very
inspiring podcast
this guy told me to get a website get a
[ __ ] website
get a website you know i don't care
i don't i i i don't care if you don't
want to i'm telling you right now
i i hope you know what they don't have
websites north [ __ ] korea
is that where you want to live you want
to live in a totalitarian state where
you cannot
have a website that's probably coming
here soon
but why don't you have one until they
take them away
okay stop being on everybody else's
platform like a cuck
i'm on twitter i'm on instagram yeah you
and everybody else
get your own url you can do what you
want you can say what you want
you won't get banned you know within
reason i mean
so you know create a website i'm not
telling you what it has to be
okay it could be a nice little journal
it could be the daily stormer i'm not
saying that i'm not
telling you to do that but from whatever
you do with it you do with it
they you know just saying that it's your
your website you know it's not
facebook it's not mark zuckerberg's
website
a ginger demon it's your website
you can do whatever you want you know
maybe upload a video of uh remember that
guy who got killed
because he the horse [ __ ] him to death
missed your hands or something like that
i forgot
i'm not
this is not a bestiality a pro betiality
stance i'm taking
but you could probably embed that video
in your website if you wanted
i mean that would be that would be a
choice
i don't know if i'd recommend that if
you're if you're like this is a business
website it is attention getting
you might just want to upload that video
and then under it go i cut hair
i also cut hair i'll come to your house
wix.com what is it go to tim dillon's
going to hell dot com
no is tim dillon d l o n s
going to hell.com go there folks that's
the site we built using wix
okay go to the bottom
10 off any wix premium plan you get 10
off you hear that
so what's your problem ten percent off
folks
you know what do you think you're gonna
get out 40 off hey [ __ ] you
people got to eat people got families to
feed you greedy pig
10 is a nice amount of change i don't
know you wix doesn't know you
we're giving you a little benefit okay
so this this ads been all over the place
because i'm i'm i've just recorded a
podcast and
my cbd ad was very good but now i'm
coming apart
and i need to eat i'm [ __ ] haven't
eaten two
my blood sugar's crashing i mean i've
eaten enough probably
i'll survive if i don't eat um
go go go get the website stop [ __ ]
around stop wasting everyone's time
get in the game of life or get the [ __ ]
out i'm not i'm not telling you to take
yourself out
i'm saying get in a game of life
life is a is a [ __ ] war
and are you gonna go to war with a
website are you gonna go to war oh go
not on your website is like
walking into i don't know you know fill
in the joke
who gives a [ __ ] really you buy this
[ __ ] thing please
so they won't fire me enough get the
goddamn website
you're gonna fail anyway you might as
well try
no one's going to your [ __ ] no one's
going to care
you know think anyone's gonna give a
[ __ ] about what you're doing out there
you're dumb [ __ ] or your sculptures
you're making in
new mexico people are gonna [ __ ] what
they're gonna start buying them
because you got a url you're toast it's
over curtains
doors shut the gates closed
everybody's going to the party but you
okay trains left the station but
that being said try
you gotta try goodbye i watched eighth
grade the bo burnham movie
on the plane it was very good reminds me
of when i was not popular
i was bullied and i was not bullied in
the era of social media that's got to be
very tough
but i will tell you this in a few weeks
we are doing an episode for
children we're doing an episode i have a
plan
for children to become popular because
that is the most important thing in
life it is a lie that it is not
and it is also a lie that the nerds all
get revenge on the popular kids that is
not true
the popular you know those kids that
bullied you it's like you know where
they are now
they're doing great they're doing great
okay one nerd succeeds
and in popular culture because it's
written by nerds
they all act but one of the things when
you grow up you realize that the losers
are losers for a reason
in my business i realize i look at
people in my business and i go
oh in high school you walked around you
had no confidence and you shouldn't have
any now
you should have no confidence now okay
so that's coming up because i was very
unpopular and then in 12th grade i was
nominated for homecoming king i did not
win
because one of the kids mothers died the
other kid's father died 9 11.
they gave it to the kid whose mother
died whatever i'm not i'm not am i
claiming russia
am i saying russia hacked it no i'm
saying that
i rose through the ranks of high school
and i'm gonna teach you how to do it's
very important
and we're going to go over different
ways to do it we're going to go over
different personalities
that you can have we did this on a video
there's different personalities you can
have depending what you bring to the
table
okay and we're going to talk about how
to be
how to infiltrate the cool kid parties
and not be a loser now a lot of you
are losers and and i'm not telling you
to go back to school
because that window's closed for many of
you like disney [ __ ] world
it's over it's over figure it out
you don't get to go back to disney world
at 40 because mom and dad didn't [ __ ]
take you
suck it up some foster kids got locked
in the closet and burnt with cigarettes
you're complaining you never went to
[ __ ] disney world
grow the [ __ ] up be an adult
jesus christ
what we're going to do we're going to do
a we are going to do
and i want to hear some stories from
people that became popular
i want you to dm and don't make them up
because i'll know
don't make them up i sniff you out you
liars but i want to talk to people
that were losers and decided at a
certain point to not be losers
because you don't have to be losers
so and i don't know how many kids listen
to this in their teens
probably none and that's probably good
for society that they don't
i'm not saying that this is this is an
adult
program this is not a show we're not
really reaching out to the tween market
here
we're not doing that okay but
if this is the one episode that we'll do
and i'm not gonna curse
and i'm not gonna talk about jeffrey
epstein although these [ __ ] kids know
already
i'm it's gonna be a family-friendly
episode i'm dead serious about this
i know that i was talking to the flight
attendant about this on american i was
telling her i was going to do this and
she finally told me to sit down she had
to prepare
she had to prepare service she thinks
she goes i got to get the card out and i
said well
listen i had a great flight attendant
today on american real
real real dark lady
i'm like i paid 40 for a more more space
seat she goes well we don't have any so
you're
you're so i'm in the last seat of the
plane with her
so so she gets she goes you might get a
refund because i'll send you some free
miles
i go uh she goes you think you're having
a bad day she goes i wasn't even
supposed to be on this flight
she goes the flight attendant who was
her husband killed herself they've been
married two years
and he killed himself in his ex-wife's
garage
and i'm like okay do we have the cheese
plate what are the snacks
okay i said to her we start talking she
goes the other day we took off we hit
windshear
when we took off she goes you hit
windshear the whole plane
goes to the side she goes there was a
scream
she goes but she used these words she
goes there was a blood curdling scream
as the plane took off she goes we got
about maybe 3000 feet up and it just
and she goes the pilot got on right away
and was like hey it's windshear we're
gonna be okay
um and i said where i go yeah we're just
[ __ ] like they call it ferrying the
plane when nobody's on them like you
ever just go up to
first class when you got nobody on the
plane she goes
she smiled she goes yes just one time we
all got to sit in first class
one time we had four people on this
plane and we all got to go right into
the front
sitting first class and i was like when
was that she goes four days after 9 11.
with a big smile on her face the thing
about flight attendants is they don't
they've made peace with death because
it's a very unnatural job to just
work 30 000 feet in the sky
all of those flight attendants they've
seen death they all do drugs
they all do they have these stopovers
they all get hammered
and all the pilots do drugs it's a
horrible job we don't pay those people
and it's a living hell they live in an
absolute hell
and they have to get on every day and go
hi
welcome is everyone happy we're going to
phoenix
is everyone excited we're going to
fannia southwest can dress it up all
they want
and they can have the people come out
and try to do stand-up and the pilots
try to be funny
and uh the flight attendants try to be
funny but i know what it really is
i know it's a bunch of people who've
made peace with death
that's who works on planes okay
but i will be doing this episode and i
will be i'm excited about it
because it's something that i feel like
people are not telling children
they're not telling children how to be
cool
they're telling them like how to go to
college order
who cares like yeah go to college
maybe but be cool
be somebody that other people like and
respect
and you don't have to abuse people you
should never bully people
that's actually not the long-term way to
be cool that's a very short-term way to
be cool
is to bully someone that's not good
it's not good you don't want to build an
act around a kid
that kid could kill themselves they
could shoot up to school then you got to
write all new [ __ ]
so what you want to do is aim high punch
up teachers administrators society at
large
or maybe you're just hot if you're hot
you got to learn how to be hot
and you got to be the right kind of hot
you know some guys
like can't be there's always like
the hot guy like some hot guys
don't know like some hot people don't
know they're hot and that's a whole
thing
it whatever we're gonna go into this but
i i i'm really excited about that
um thanks to everyone who came out to
hilarity's in cleveland we had fun
however uh it was the first time i had
like six people kicked out and i never
have anyone kicked out
but i do a joke about trump and it's not
a pro-trump joke it's just really a joke
about people being insane
on social media and as soon as i
mentioned trump um
all these people were like
started booing audibly in the crowd they
were like boo
and i flipped that i should have taped
it and i was like what the [ __ ] are you
booing at
like it's a joke i'm like don't you
realize
that he's gonna win again because you
people are such annoying [ __ ]
you can what do you think you're doing
what do you think you're accomplishing
right now
by booing a joke and you're yelling
trump is a [ __ ]
i've never i've never been a trump guy
there's nothing pro-trump
but now of course now that i said all
that it activated some of the pro-trump
people in the audience
you know so i'm like so i start i just
start losing it i'm like q anon's coming
a few people in the audience were like
cute you know just people are crazy
i'm just i'm like whipping it into a
frenzy
you know it's turning into just a
regular day in portland
another street fight listen just shut up
if you go to a comedy show and you don't
like something just shut your mouth
you're not doing anything that's what
people need to be told
you're not doing anything by your
opinion
i don't know what has to happen in this
country or this world
for people to realize that the sole act
of having an opinion
it is irrelevant it doesn't matter like
first of all your opinion for most of
you isn't
based on anything it's r you're
regurgitating something you
heard or you're trying to get attention
you don't have a educated opinion
you didn't do the work trying to figure
anything out
i know that's why i don't have opinions
on a lot of things
because i don't know yet yes i don't
think israel should build the
settlements and like bulldoze the
palestinians out of their houses
right but i also think israel has like a
right to exist
but i don't i haven't like done the
issue i haven't like studied
and then these idiots like we we did the
whole thing about take out food i was
ranting about that
a few people were like whoa we need to
go do comedy about nothing now
about take out food no i'm writing a new
hour on the mideast peace process you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
do you know what comedy even is do you
know what it is
i'm a clown why don't you
do something i demand my comedy
be intellectual and i demand that it uh
conform to everything that i already
believe
and i i don't want it to be about people
taking food to go
i want it to be about health care
i want you to make medicare for all
funny
and if you don't i'm out yeah we should
have health care i've said it
70 million times i'm i hope and pray to
god
that somebody has done more work and
research into the topic than i have
i have a job i have to do the job that i
have
there's other people doing their jobs
okay you [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is what happens now comedy's just
gonna be about nothing
i want it to be about bernie sanders
i want it to be funny and i wanted to be
about
hmos what
what are you crazy
this insipid like i just
i get a little frustrated with with some
people out there
i'm very grateful for you know there's a
lot of great fans of this show
and you don't have to like or agree with
what we do we don't we don't we don't
care
whatever you you comment is lovely you
know that's fine
as long as you're consuming the product
you don't care what you say afterwards
you know i used to do cocaine
with a girl who would always complain
about the quality of the cocaine to the
cocaine dealer
and he would just you know his attitude
was well you're buying it
as long as you're buying it you have the
right to say you know she'd be like you
know this isn't like the last time
remember that time you got it it was
better
divorce it's very [ __ ] up it's [ __ ]
the kids up out there
how long have we done we got more right
in an hour we're right in an hour
um but i mean that's my thing
bill maher said something about people
watching comic book movies everybody
flipped out
i said something about adults not
celebrating halloween i said hey
if you got to wear like an edgy
halloween costume if that's your only
way to be
why don't you give the holiday back to
children because that's who it was for
i'm not go go and it was not really
directed and everybody was dressing up
it was kind of directed at the people
that are going to get fired because they
went to a party dressed as a twin towers
i'm like
well i can do that i'm a commit if you
if you're if you're a kindergarten
teacher maybe hold
hold off on that it is what it is
you know if you want to go as a korean
person i'm not
for the cultural appropriation i really
don't care what you dress up as but
maybe in this climate it's not smart
to go as a guatemalan i don't know what
some of these people do together so i
just tweeted like i was like hey
give halloween back to children don't
dress up
buy a house get a job whatever people
went nuts it was the most controversial
thing i've ever
said telling people to not telling
adults to not wear a costume
think of everything i've said
the country's run by demons they're
sucking the energy out of children
the country's run by crime families that
murder that sell drugs to traffic in
human beings
and what really upset people is i said
why don't you not dress up
in a costume that's what really got
people it's like this disney world
article flip
people the [ __ ] out because somebody
suggested
that maybe they
give it up give the give this child like
one like that's a problem with disney
world's like all the people there like
approach the world with
child like wonder oh it's child like
well i feel like a kid again
i just feel like a kid don't
don't feel like a child there's a time
to be a child and here's another one and
this is gonna really get people
and we'll do this one we're gonna do
this one by the way and then we're gonna
get out of here
folks you're not gonna like it are you
ready
man you are not gonna like this one
this one's gonna be this one's gonna be
one that people get really angry about
are you ready prepare
beast take a seat i imagine many of you
are i imagine many people aren't
listening to this on the elliptical
i could be wrong
the time to smoke marijuana
is in your late teens and early to mid
20s after that
it should be very rare
it should not be all the time for most
people and don't give me like
well rogan and dude that guy has a
constitution you will never have
yeah you want to yeah yeah that guy's
got three jobs he's running up and down
hills
he can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
don't use an example of like the four
people
that are succeeding in life he's one of
five people that are doing well
don't use that example get real
[ __ ] losers come at me with a okay
the weed every day folks not a good look
not a good look
not to move
not the move is there anything
more fun to being 17 or 18 or 19 and
getting high
going to taco bell laughing your ass off
okay
here's where that's less fun your late
30s
it is not as fun now many of you are
angry at me but you know i'm right
i'm not a perfect person i get it i go
to taco bell sober
that's unforgivable that is
i mean i go sober 35 year old sober
person
will eat taco bell that is in and of
itself
a crime it should be against the law
but cut it out
with the vape the weed you know
everybody's
high all the time
folks things are coming you're not going
to want to be high for them
you're going to want to be sober when it
comes
you know what's coming okay
everybody let's talk a little bit about
uh physical conditioning i know that uh
we may not do that as much as
other podcasts do but it's very
important you know we really don't
we really don't go into uh wellness and
uh you know uh uh
mind-body spirit connection as much as
we should but
you know that's really important and i
think people
that uh have happy successful lives
all seem to have some kind of
deeply rooted understanding of how their
body works
and when it's you know
when it's at maximum levels of
efficiency
and you know
what fuel the body needs
and these are all very important things
and i think we don't do enough about
that and that's my fault that's really
on me
you know i'm the captain of the ship and
a lot of times we uh we get lost
but there's a lot out there
and i want to start when we talk about
the body i want to start with the balls
um because there's a lot going on
and there's a lot that needs to be
addressed
um a lot of people need to clean up
their area
down there i bought a house in 2007
with a subprime mortgage uh during a
cocaine binge
that house has been foreclosed on i have
lost it
um the legal proceedings have been
completed it was taken
you know it was a collateral and you
know the house was
you know repossessed and i no longer own
it clearly
and my credit has been decimated because
of that and
i guess the debt was written off i don't
really it's neither here nor there
the point is that that house had about
an acre of property
and that acre of property was untamed
wild long island grass
big raccoon lived in a tree in the
backyard and used to walk around the
backyard
but if you looked at the lawn you would
know what was going on in that house
which was a lot of pain you would see
the lawn and you would say
this gives me a very good indication of
what's happening in that house
which was nothing good bills piling up
by the door that nobody
was opening and nobody was paying just a
tiny bit of fuel
just enough fuel to keep that house
going no more
people could see that they could sense
it they could see the fear and the
desperation
just by looking at the wild overgrown
unmanaged lawn
so when we talk about your your dick
your your your private area your balls
your taint your grundle
you need to keep these things where
people look at them and they go
oh that's a that's a respectable
individual that takes care of himself
and takes care of others this is
somebody i want to build a relationship
with
maybe a life with maybe this is somebody
i want to have children with
because they have taken care of
themselves
manscaped has redesigned the electric
trimmer
their invention is the lawnmower 2.0
skin safe technology i used to before
you know i would hook up with somebody
that i met on uh grinder or whatever
back in the day on craigslist i would
have to
try to manscape myself with you know uh
something and every now and then you
would nick yourself
and now it's embarrassing and and and
sometimes you'd have to just not go and
meet up with that person
because you're bloody and that's not the
move you never want to show up with a
bloody dick
so what you try to do is you know
you basically have to be very very
careful um and that's why this
new manscape lawnmower 2.0 is great
because it has skin
safe technology okay
it is small easy to hold and designed to
get into all your nooks and crannies
without snagging your sack
you do not want to puncture your scrotum
okay no more using the same trimmer on
your face
that you use on your [ __ ] junk
use the right tools for the job
manscaped is designed with your junk in
mind
you know how it gets down there in the
summer sweaty
stinky a lot of people like that you
know
a lot of people don't want you to shower
they want to get the whole you
you know they want to get they want to
get smacked in the face with a
little bit of salt a little bit of
salted caramel
you know some people don't some people
want you to deodorize every part of your
body but it's like what the [ __ ] is the
point
you know are you trying to [ __ ] a
chemical
trying to [ __ ] a person you know this is
neither here nor there
again but it's just a little i'm just
editorializing on a concept
but just in time for summer they've got
the crop preserver an
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer
if you're one of these people that is
ashamed of your own scent
or maybe your partner doesn't want you
got to ease somebody in
to really smack at them with a sweaty
ball
so you should start with a moisturizer
and a deodorizer
after you've been in a relationship for
a little while then you can take the hog
out in any condition and just smack them
around with it
but in the beginning you've got to get
them in with a
a low interest rate let's say so it
smells nice and it's
nice and
one of the things here in this ad they
say you put deodorant on your pits why
are you not putting deodorant on the
smelliest part of your body
well i don't know i mean i think it's a
little different but some people like
gross armpits too i mean what
you know listen buy this product because
it should you know most people don't
most people don't want sweaty smelly
balls but there are people that do
they want that okay but what's nice is
giving someone that choice but nobody
wants too much bush
this is the fact nobody wants too much
bush
nobody wants there's that fat cat i have
on instagram oscar
and his fur grows so much that he gets
burrs stuck in it
these little spiky i don't know where
they come i think they come from a tree
but he gets the burrs start any he's got
fleas and mites
he has an entire ecosystem living on him
like the sloth if you've ever been the
sloth in the amazon
i like british people say sloth and i
like that but the
the sloth has an entire ecosystem of
bugs living on him
he is a host for an entire community
of bugs which i think is kind of nice i
like
things like that i i find life
fascinating i've always wanted to go to
the amazon
and uh but you have to have a lot of you
got to get a lot of shots and i don't
really have the
i don't have the money to go to ohio so
what i'm saying is that the bush needs
to go
bold deodorant moisturizer that's great
you know but somebody also might be like
hey with all due respect
let's not take a shower just hit me with
whatever you got listen this is you know
some people are into this but i'm just
saying get 20 off free shipping with the
code tim at manscape.com
literally they just sent me one of these
things the lawnmower it is amazing
it is you never feel better when you are
shaving your balls you feel
safe you feel like you can do it
hammered i don't suggest that you feel
like you can do it drunk
you know it's a you feel like you could
just kind of freestyle it down there and
you're not gonna
nick yourself because they really do
have this advanced technology it really
is good
you do need to shave your balls the
norelco body groom's not that great
that's what usually everybody else kind
of uses it's not that great
the body groom i'm telling you i've used
it um
you know and and i'm i'm telling you
it's a it's a big deal
tim is the code 20 off manscape.com
that's 20
off free shipping manscape.com if you're
not getting laid
and you want to get lit you got to clean
up your dick does it really matter how
big your dick is
you know uh it doesn't really matter
uh i mean
you know there are people that are gonna
want bigger dicks that's a fact
be into that
you know you know lots of them but the
obsession about dick size
is is probably a waste of time because
there's nothing you can really do about
it
unless that product advertises on the
show and then
we'll you know fix that for you but as
of right now it seems
like you're just you get what you get
and
but what you can do is really
you've all been to a house that's not
that great but they've done a lot of
work
you know what i mean where you walk in
the house and they're really proud of it
it's kind of sadder in a way but they're
really proud of it the yard's very nice
you've ever been to a small yard
that's immaculate and you go oh this is
nice
because they take pride in where they
live that's the way you should feel
about your [ __ ] and balls
can be big maybe it's a big beautiful
you know
you know big uh maybe you got a big huge
you know rib eye steak down there maybe
you have a petite
filet mignon you know an eight ounce
filet
that a divorce school teacher would
order with a kendall jackson chardonnay
i know it's not my business
or maybe you have a big porterhouse for
three at peter lugers you just want to
swing it i've seen certain penises where
i go
that person's life should be amazing
like there's no excuse for that person
but then some of them don't have good
lives
because they just have this big dick and
they play with it and then they [ __ ]
whatever they want and they don't get
any other skills
because their dick is so huge that it's
amazing
i'm just saying this is what happens now
so what i'm saying is this if you have a
dick that you don't love
do manscaped get yourself in the right
deodorize your balls okay women
don't want smelly balls if men don't
really care probably
men will [ __ ] you with whatever women
for the most part unless you get a real
freak a real
you know like from dusk till dawn
vampire type and that's what
you know kind of what you want not to
marry but you know for an hour
um so you got to deodorize your bowls
moisturize them because people want
a soft nice ball you know
i mean this is this is what i meant when
i said we wanted to do more about health
and wellness
this is really the direction we wanted
to go into i didn't know if you thought
we were going to start talking about
intermittent fasting but clean the area
up
you know it's very interesting um
you know this is this is all i can tell
you folks tim
is the code 20 off manscaped.com
and send in photos to the show before
and after photos
before you've trimmed yourself and after
you've trimmed yourself
send in photos to the show um
i will be the judge we'll see we'll see
how you've done we will not comment on
the size of your penis
we will simply address uh everything
else that's going on
and we'll be like look at this nicked
himself the balls look moisturized
you got to moisturize your balls folks
gotta deodorize and moisturize those
balls
do it really get this the the the the
the [ __ ]
you need this here's the thing you need
it and the other thing on the market the
norelco thing
isn't good and then there's really
nothing else
i'm telling you there's not a lot out
there
especially if you're a bigger person
you're a fat person
you need to do this it's not a
negotiation
i'm just saying there's nobody wants a
[ __ ]
crop of disgusting hair
you want a nice
like fit trim area
or you know or you're uh you'd be an
incel i don't know what to tell you i
mean those guys seem to enjoy it
i mean there's you know certainly some
of them in the audience huh if i
uh compliment whitney cummings or
something these people lose their minds
you know take it as a direct attack to
them that i have recognized another
woman as a human being on earth
they can't handle it they start flipping
out gotta attack you
who are you what is this these rules
they hate gay people but they only want
to spend time and talk to men
it's very interesting it's very
interesting breed
dudes that want to just spend time with
other dudes and suck each other off you
might as well
what are you doing you're wasting time
you're playing video games all day you
might as well [ __ ] get off
otherwise you're gonna have to learn to
speak to a member of the opposite sex
and that means deodorizing your balls
shaving them
you know get in the game boys girls this
isn't for girls is it
who cares if you're a girl that's a boy
do this what do i don't care
don't start with me now do you need a
dick to be a boy maybe not
shave your [ __ ] with this that's not
what it's for
but i can't tell you how to live do what
you want
you know whatever go maybe you have a
penis that was made out of a [ __ ]
maybe you have a vagina that was made
out of a penis
i don't know it's 2019
and everybody is having fun
so manscape.com
promo code tim thank you
some kid just texted me some guy that i
thought i was gonna
i don't know if we were gonna hook up or
whatever he's gonna come out to la and
stay with me
we've been talking he clearly doesn't
want to that's okay he used the old i'm
gonna spend time with my brother
which i that's my favorite that's my
favorite ah
i'm gonna spend time with my fam you
know it's like if i was zac efron would
you still be
would you still be spending time with
him you know
he goes well i'm just kind of going to
hang out my brother and i'm like okay
that's fair i get it i
listen i i get it but i just love like
you know and then he asked me he's like
are you close with your family it's like
listen listen we don't know i get
i get it you can let you can let me down
you can let me down i i think he thought
like i was going to be like like
i was going to be like showing him
around l.a you don't have to come if you
don't like it you don't like it whatever
you come out you don't like it's fine
it's not a big deal go [ __ ] everyone
else i don't care i'll still buy you
lunch i'll still be the loser
i'll still take you out for avocado
toast we'll throw lobster on it then you
can go [ __ ] some other dude
i don't care i'll still be the mark
that's fine i don't have a problem with
that
i put myself in that position but i just
think it's
funny he was like yeah i'm just gonna
spend time with her
it's like larry silverstein they asked
him why he wasn't he had a meeting at
the world trade center he didn't go he
goes
yeah you know my wife said i should go
to this doctor's appointment you know
and i
i figured is that it larry
that's how you made all these billions
listening to the uh the little woman
i'm not saying he shouldn't have but i'm
just saying a guy like him doesn't
really seem like
it's an interesting day he's like my
wife was just nagging me and i
i finally decided you know she made a
good point
i'll go to the doctor uh this day i'm
not
saying anything folks i'm just saying
it's fun isn't it fun
it's just fun that's all not a big deal
nothing's a big deal
i'm a famous celebrity and things are
great
i live in a mansion and i'm very happy
i do a lot for the world and the world
does a lot for me
i hustle i grind
i'm positive i'm positivity all day
all night positive i don't make any
excuses
i don't like them as the great gary
vaynerchuk says
kindness is delicious kindness
is delicious that was a tweet from gary
vanyerchuck
who is my spirit animals my god when i
feel low
i go to get like all great entrepreneurs
they need that how could you create a
business without those words of wisdom
because you forget how delicious
kindness is and that's by the way how
people build businesses being kind
that's how they do it that's how they do
it
that's how empires are built by being a
kind
person that's like the story in the
bible jesus you remember he had all the
casinos
jesus owned all the casinos because he
was he was kind
and and and people love that the romans
love that
tim dilloncomedy.com for all your comedy
needs
please go to the southern run folks
don't don't [ __ ] around with me here
i'm doing one-nighters i'm coming to uh
first of all america comedy code the
first through the third this might come
out
you might have missed that don't go the
next week when i'm not there like disney
world and try to recapture it
it's over um but august 4th
through the 8th i'm going to be down
doing
nashville charlotte north carolina
huntsville alabama hoover alabama
i'm going to be at the comedy zone in
charlotte i'm going to be at zany's in
nashville i'm going to be a stand-up
live in huntsville alabama
i'm going to be at the star dome in
hoover alabama doing comedy
really funny guy todd riley's going to
be there with me and
we're going to have some fun please if
you're in those areas grab tickets to
those shows
i'm also going to be in north carolina
at good night's comedy club
uh in raleigh the 22nd to the 24th
uh come out to that and then we've got
more dates coming up
the patreon is coming many of you have
asked
it is coming here's some of the things
that will be on the patreon
we will have all of the archives from
gas digital two and a half years
all of the great interviews i did with
all those great writers if you're into
the conspiracy stuff russ baker nick
bryant
you know the director of who took johnny
mark eliade who wrote a great book about
the russian mob
we have comedians like dan soder bobby
kelly bonnie mcfarlane we have a lot of
really cool
episodes we have just great episodes of
me and ray we talk about all kinds of
stuff
and what's fun about that is you can
kind of chart
you can see the rise of trump through
the show
and you could see how things are kind of
coming apart and it's a very interesting
show because of what we
who we have on and are the way that we
are positioned like not in the
mainstream
we're positioned on the fringe and
watching the fringe
the [ __ ] that we always talked about
bleed into the mainstream
and watching all of a sudden everybody
start talking about things that we've
been talking about
everybody you know you know whether it
was like deep state dynamics
whether it was intelligence agencies
whether it was human trafficking i mean
it's really wild to watch that happen
it's a great archive for a road trip or
whatever and it's going to be available
for like five dollars a month you'll get
an extra episode every week
plus the archive whole archive for five
bucks a month
it's pretty [ __ ] good deal and if you
can't afford that no problem just keep
telling your friends to watch the show
uh listen to the show we appreciate it
you know
um i will end on this too um
the hatred of certain comics is odd to
me
you people hate certain people like you
hate schumer
here's a deal if you you don't have to
agree with amy politically i was in an
argument with somebody the other day
amy is unquestionably talented she's
insanely funny she's a beast of a comic
you don't have to like her
it is what it is and i really don't
think she's stealing jokes and i i i had
this argument with somebody
the jokes in question and everyone's
gonna be like what is she giving you a
job
i've never met her we met once in the
hyatt lobby
she looked at me he was like hello i was
like hey there is no
i'm not going on tour but there's none
of that i'm just saying
people throw [ __ ] out there and there's
a lot of people that listen to show
disagree with me
you know you make people into like the
boogeyman like she's satan
for whatever if you don't like it don't
[ __ ] watch
who cares i guarantee she's funnier than
you
if you hate her and you're listening i
guarantee you
she's better at being funny than you are
okay guaranteed
you might not like her doesn't matter
she doesn't give a [ __ ] if you've
noticed
she's doing well and i i get no benefit
from saying this i'm not
there's no she's been generous to comics
good to comics
i mean not to me i'm not in her circle
but like
and whatever it's not only her she's
like one that people throw a lot of hate
at
but if you don't like it commit just
move the [ __ ] on
who care enough people message me lord
this person sucks or
that person so go get who cares
enough they're better than you
all the people that you hate are funnier
than you
all the people that you think are hacks
or whatever
they're they're better at this and use a
[ __ ] hard thing to do
okay it's a hard thing to do you think
you're funny
well cause you said the n-word in the
break room at the water treatment
facility
and everybody laughed great
but you know enough already
you know doesn't mean you don't you have
to like people doesn't mean you can't
[ __ ] on people
but stop making people into gods and
stop making them into satan
nobody's a god all these comedians all
these [ __ ] celebrity
people you build up as gods i know half
of these people
they're doing a job it makes you happy
good be an adult this is that disney
world [ __ ] man
this is that childlike wonder this is
like i'm catching fireflies in the
backyard
grow the [ __ ] up enough
stop making a god out of trump stop
making a god out of ocasio-cortez
he's a game show host a criminal and a
liar she's a bartender
who's you know seems confused
but has some you know right she has some
of the right instincts
she knows everything's [ __ ] i don't
know if she knows how to fix it
she knows everything's [ __ ] but this
whole thing about deifying people
and then tearing them down it's a deeply
immature thing
it means you've got nothing going on it
means that you've got nothing
going on that everything has to be about
somebody that you love or hate
the world is more complex than that some
of the people that you really like are
schmucks
doesn't mean they're not really great at
their job and some of the people
that you might not like are lovely
people that are great people and you'll
never know
you don't know you'll never know people
until you meet them
until you and even after you meet them
like you don't know a lot of people
at the end of the day you go through
your entire life you look back
you don't really know a lot of people
you you get an idea of people
but you don't know them that well so
this this idea that like
you can you can take um
you know you could take a real hard
stance you know i
love this person donald trump you like
you know it it's immature and the people
on the left do it too
the squad the squad is gonna
stop looking for like gods and stuff
it's embarrassing it's one of the
reasons
that we're we're we're living in a
rapidly decaying
society because everybody's looking for
some type of avatar to get behind it's
stupid
it's childish you know i mean i don't
know how else to say it
no [ __ ] house to say it you know you
talk to people sometimes and they just
they seem to not get it's not that
interesting
everything in hollywood's not a
pedophile cult there are there are
but everything everybody that's doing
well
in la is not evil they're too boring to
be evil
trust me if they were evil they'd be a
hell of a lot more interesting
a lot of them are just vapid and lucky
but that's so
that world is even harder to live in the
world where they're not
demons that have been selected by no
they're lucky
they got it you didn't there you go
there's your world
it's not always a preordained
you know and i know a lot of people like
to think of it and now some of it is
you know when we talk about who's
president this is a different story
okay this is different we're talking
about somebody with a cooking show or a
[ __ ] you know
whatever people are doing out here a
sitcom
[ __ ] somebody's on a dance
competition like guys enough
the illuminati is not hand selecting
everybody on dancing with the [ __ ]
stars
they don't have the time it's just not
what it is
i'm not defending l.a [ __ ] on la all the
time people are like oh you're living in
l.a now
you're defending all that no there's
demons here to be sure
to be sure but a lot of people here are
just lucky i don't think people
can comprehend that they're in the right
place at the right time
they had a few of the right they got the
right look
people i don't think you comprehend that
because that is kind of a more
terrifying world
than the world where everybody's
elevated based on this
you know ominous whatever just is what
it is i'm not saying that there aren't
deals that are made
i'm not saying that you know it's not a
lot darker than
people would imagine but it's dark in a
different way than you would imagine
i think it's lonely there's a lot of
loneliness
there's a lot of indifference people
really don't give a [ __ ] about you
people do things for a very long period
of time
and then they get a little attention a
little a heat and then people start
going
oh who do they [ __ ] what do they do who
they haven't
it's just that they bang their head
against the wall they shredded their
entire life
they've ruined every relationship
they've had they've mortgaged their
entire future on one thing
and some sometimes it works a lot of
times it doesn't
the majority of times it doesn't but
sometimes it works so this whole
idea that everybody out there
who gets anything either one doesn't
deserve it
or has gotten it for some [ __ ] like
you know
reason that is like shrouded in mystery
and they must know the right person no
no the people that do
a lot of the picking and the choosing
here are lazy they're lazy and they're
bad at their job
there's a few of them that are price
nefarious movers and shakers
manipulating but it's a very very high
level it's really not at the level i'm
at
not even really at the level a few
levels above me
a lot of it is just simply happenstance
not all of it
but some of it so i think the idea of
deifying people and making them gods
comes from that
the idea that
that these people are super human either
in a good sense or a bad sense like
they're either demons from hell
or they're gods that walk the earth no a
lot of them just
worked hard took risks and got lucky
not all of them but some of them and
and that's the whole thing casio cortez
a human being donald trump's a human
being
they were able to leverage certain
things they had certain qualities
and that doesn't mean by the way that
they're not backed by very powerful
people
or that they're not compromised
none of that is the case but what i'm
saying is that
making them into they they have the same
qualities that you have
that many of us have you just don't
finally tune and hone those qualities
and market them or make them into
something which is i'm not saying you
have to
go fall in love go walk on the beach
much better life i'm not saying you have
to want to
you know try to you know run the world
and run the planet
but you know one of the things that i
realized about when i met
elites i met people that had gone to
really good schools
their families had a lot of money in
many cases they were stunningly ignorant
about the way the world actually worked
because they had never been
on a public bus they had never they
didn't even in the business that i mean
you meet people
that are very very good at what they do
but they're so high up that they don't
see what's going on under them
they can't really conceptualize what the
masses are doing
or or what direction things are moving
in and it's because a lot of those
elites
doesn't mean they're gods it doesn't
mean that they possess these superhuman
qualities
it just means they're in a very small
world and it's very insulated and it's
very insular
you know and it's a world that gives
them
endless privilege and endless benefits
and [ __ ] like that
but a lot of people are not
technically elites a lot of them have
attained an elite position
because they were at the right place
at the right [ __ ] time and they had
the right [ __ ] and it just kind of
clicked
and if you can make peace with that
you'll you're okay because listen there
are real conspiracies there is real [ __ ]
going on
nobody is i mean very few people i mean
there are people that have done
you know that focused on the more than i
do but what clouds the real [ __ ]
what clouds the epstein stuff what
clouds the franklin scandal
what clouds jfk what cloud's very
legitimate questions about these things
is when you start really painting with
this crazy broad brush
and throwing like an open mic you're
just throwing out
you know premises of this person and
that person and this person that
it's like at the end of the day you have
to accept
that a lot of this literally
is [ __ ] luck not in my
case i'm talent
that's why i'm on a porch with no money
you understand that's talent
luck i'd be on power
goodbye